hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play seven days no
affiliation to the ring that I know of I
have no idea really but it's a game that
was made by oh my gosh I've totally
forgot his name but the link is in the
description as always you can find it
there it's someone in my room okay
anyway so as you can tell it's a horror
game that's all I have to say about that
so let's go let's go hello and it's also
in the pixelated style of some of the
games it's from like gamejolt a lot
games from gamejolt are made on the game
creator engine I believe I'm not sleepy
at this kind of well well I hope you're
ready for your morning cup of coffee of
doom why you so dark in my house why do
I have it locked it's my house why is it
locked
hang on is this one locked that's locked
how about locked away some demons that
would make sense
hello my grandfather [ __ ] that Ike the
grandfather clock that I keep in my
strange bookshelf area many ancient
books well that's not a good sign do you
even know where you live man do you even
understand what's going on come rooms
this uh okay I can't turn it off oh no
oh is that blood on that painting oh I
can't turn it off oh no right
welp I'm gonna die pretty much set in
stone at this point anybody hear
anything that I need to know about E and
D oh no I can't go through the whole
alphabet I'll just stick with E and E
cuz it's the end for me oh I can
actually open these I had no idea
well then I might have to go back and
check the other things because I had no
idea that you could actually open stuff
huh interesting
this door is stuck well gosh darn it
fix your house man hi well you're
probably just a little kid for more the
lock rooms have any idea who you are why
what's with the bars what kind of freaky
house do you live in man
right then oh sit Sam thought that SATs
in good it's just as Sam and my visions
gone all wibbly-wobbly so iron bars what
on the walls I'm some psycho killer
crazy person aren't I and now
everything's gone red tell me your
secret Sam nothing why is my vision go
wibbly-wobbly
Oh duh Sam oh well I'm an idiot sorry
about that everyone Sam da put the
letters in the box put the letters in
the Box I'm an idiot okay Sam s that
took me like way longer than it should
have
Sam I am
yes I got hello
was that just a squeak of the box hose
that something else what was that
hello hello hello
well looks like I'll be hitting no dusty
trail here what I use my key on library
where's the library what is that thing
in the corner what the heck is that
oh there we go hello who knew who knew
oh no oh no I refuse to take any part of
all of this there are many ancient books
there are many many ancient books ah
yeah yeah I gotta get and I ain't gonna
give me no thank you I don't want any
okay is there anything in this library
that I can get before I get out of here
I don't want hey thank you I didn't see
anything in there I'm not going back in
there all right fine
you know likey okay there's nothing in
here oh there's a trail of blood well I
just gotta click on all the bookshelves
they're all ancient books there are many
ancient books I don't see anything
though see anything that I need there's
just a bunch of ancient books many
ancient books let me just cut through
this very observationally and try to
find anything that it's like that hand
just appears and then goes away really
quickly I don't know why it's quite
annoying but I don't see anything if
there is something that I can interact
with it's going away too quickly before
I can get to it
wait what's that oh no that's just a
book never mind come in here oh here
what was I
what are you how did I touch your your
book did I touch the one book that you
didn't want me to touch hello
if you're gonna do something just do it
I don't like the waiting game huh I
found a black K - what that's bull
I don't startle me nothing to be scared
about though I found a black key here's
a black door torn tomb mix Furman handed
oh hello
flatty man what are you doing here
why is there a baby cage I didn't mean
that was the cage for babies I meant
that's a tiny cage why
ioki little white key all right then
for the white door something appears to
be okay what was that what happened what
happened what happened happen oh do do
do oh that I don't know I don't know I
don't all has a page on the ground who's
it's a says it's not time yet for or
what
playtime Oh sleepy time good night
everybody
huh no sleepy I just got up ha
NoHo this door is stuck
his book sucks check I'll check it out
hmm
called sacrifice and murder Oh
sacrificing but not super awesome
markiplier sacrifice baby cries zombie
dumb hello Sam
the greatest illusion is the existence
of a unique truth hello who could that
be
Toby L don't hell you bastards go to
hell oh no another babycakes I don't
like all righty then
ruined key well it seemed to be usable
for me hello everything over here a dead
plant man I don't kick care of my plants
I'm not doing a good job as caretaker I
mean I got the whole baby situation down
with all my baby kick why why red why
right now
haunted stove haunted fridge another box
anything in there no why go red then why
you go red why you go red oh no another
TV that I cannot turn off I'll just sit
down relax for a bit
oh I can turn it off flippy flippy
flippy flippy floppy leave it on for a
bit
leave it on hmm where's all my babies
cool
Wow alright then okay
is that Princess Zelda G I like your new
look
blood dripping from your eyeballs that's
good it's good good thing
alright I've officially triggered my own
insanity and I'm going to leave forever
where did I come from where did I go
where did I come from cotton-eye Joe I
don't know if I was supposed to do some
Mel's over there but I've got a wanting
to go away go away from there there's a
new blood ah I thought that hi John
hi did I I thought oh no no no you got
to be kidding me
no not this I hate the hallway true say
it's not time yet what I'll go sleep
then this is now gonna be the third day
well goody goody goody rooty-tooty a
Manchu tea we're having a fun time we're
having a fun time keep the way don't
look back yeah my motivational note for
the day nothing in the drawer how I
could have hoped keep the way so don't
look back don't panic
don't look back when you can't go back I
feel a great present behind me
you do who you don't look back don't
look back
no the big don't look back little one
look I can't look back I'm looking back
hello is something here
okey goodie goodie goodie goodie
I like me when I get a key locked oh um
yeah sweet I'm too many too many locked
doors to many locked doors nice setting
I can turn this on and off no problem
let's leave it on this game is me
messing with me
this games messing with my brain my
brain has already been thoroughly messed
with it's really dark now it's dark now
to the lab to the lab what kind of what
kind of crazy lab are you talking about
oh hello lady you gonna go all crazy on
me I can't see two inches in front of my
face which is bad hello oh just feeeeel
the wall just feel the wall what the
hell why is this water why is that like
that why is that like that huh huh huh
ha ha ha okay
was there something on the ground I
can't see the ground I can't even see
the ground alright then
okey-dokey there's nothing in this room
there was no point coming in there was
there I don't even know where I've been
yet I can't tell anymore
locked cuz I can't see anything
ya been in there I'm gonna leave these
doors open cuz I know I've been in here
I think at least where am I going
I don't know I don't know but I think
then I've reached the end and I got to
go back out into the other hallway why
is my fiction change this is very very
not fair there we go okay finally oh
don't know what I'm happy about oh
there's a dead body that door just
closed behind me probably why why dead
body outline oh now I can see oh hello
what are you you want to fight man
that's right you better run stop lying
to yourself you must choose where to
live well what do you mean I picked this
house it's nice it's a little Deamonte
whoa I saw something I saw something I
saw something I saw something you can't
fool me
it's not time yet
aha fourth day alrighty then I'm
well-versed in this I'm totally
experienced in all of what this is which
is bad from my immense knowledge of
horror games I can tell this is bad
hi
is this another don't look back scenario
good late I guess cuz I'm already
looking back no topic you stop it
what's with the blood on the wall haha
power can i rot no no no we're gonna run
wherever the door stuck go that way
arrows blood on the wall arrows arrows
open am i still running or what am i
still running am i still running am i
still running is this me running I can't
tell who you lied to be here you lied to
me you lied to me you lied to me you
lied I gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
use the damn key okay I gotta do it
again right I gotta do it again now
gonna let me go that easy they were
stuck Oh door stuff good for the door
good good good yeah run okay running
running quickly quick like bunny gotta
go in the the rooms are gonna lie to me
everything's gonna lie everything's a
lie gotta go in here first grab the key
Sam
room key go through there go into here
get the key
yes again that guy
Suzy Suzy runnin runnin runnin runnin
runnin runnin runnin runnin
go to sleep okay oh I guess ah no no no
no no open the damn doors ah there's
blood on the pillow
what is it good
listen come here look at me new loo you
found it found what your secret porn
collection visit the room
Sandra
who's Sam okay reacts react you this
little face rise notes a not time yet
52 Pro till 5 like Baus oh I am Sam
maybe I'm not leaving yet I just cut up
me sir fait un cassia Vita horse monter
la awesome loss monter Elmont their lame
on hi
you cannot continue like this didn't you
understand why you are you here alright
then
hello eyeballs
hi are you flanking at me looking at me
I look right back at you well this is
just herbing hi okay I'll go down this
way I'll play your little game you over
oke what to expect they've pretty much
pulled every single trick on the book on
me so I don't know what they can get me
with now like ID you could tell that
jump-scare was a little expected hello
it's dark in here
oh look it's another baby Cajun okay I
can get the great off with this
screwdriver yes yes yes yes what's over
here whoa
how do I get back here already ah I
won't complain swagger brauch control
the Crouch scrub Oh what are these
pressure switches yep what why what what
did I do I'm sorry I pressed the wrong
pressure switch that one are those wrong
okay correct
dammit this one and just straight line
oh come on
well what am I supposed to do
oh I did that whatever I did that you
all saw I did that I did that you are
starting to feel dizzy aren't you maybe
a little
the perspective a little disorienting I
got some blood in my eyeballs apparently
hi Clark hello couch where's my TV he
took my TV damn it Sam
hi pitter-patter of young footsteps my
baby's escaped
I gotta go catch my babies all right
there are many ancient books many
ancient books and a key mini agent books
Aniki yeah right
I'm beginning to imagine that I really
am some horrific monster if I'm living
in this house with Sam I mean I either
am Sam or something else clever and
interesting hi Sam try to open your eyes
I am my eyes open as they can be six day
till fun Oh way to go way to go marklar
you're the best
I don't even have a bed anymore you took
away my bed kind of douche are you Oh
starting off with the red eyes right
away you have red dry eyes stop what
what what what what is that got a
freaking mannequin yeah - I was okay
don't like Marika's get away get away
get away get away
I don't like mannequins
hi I'd rather see you than them okay
Jesus
okay what's going on with you Sam
something I need to do with you you're
in a cage in a but uh that's right
forget it
what am i maybe lose my screwdriver you
little stupid little kids kid mannequins
my viewer your the babies in the cages
whatever Sam what side of the bars is a
prisoner
you faced prison for ugly hi what do I
do about you I don't have a screwdriver
anymore I'm just gonna have a staring
contest with you go suck an egg go suck
an egg you can't no fear creates the
cake fine now I'm gonna go to sleep and
I kid
get me out here please thank you that's
what like mannequins
okay this is the calm before the storm I
know this you're gonna pull some other
stunt right out of my nightmare book oh
this looks familiar
uh where am I see this before demonic
alter nooses well I guess I'm gonna hang
those little mannequin bastards and go
on my merry way
logic gadget all right come here my
strangle you - ha ha ha ha ha ha oh look
there's another hole just for me I guess
oh my head through the news you put my
head through that noose can't put my
head through the noose oh I get it
did I not open the doors for all the
Americans and I've only gotten 5 now -
follow me this game is beyond what I
expected
this game is pretty awful it's pretty
high I need to get through there
maybe I don't know can I go to sleep yet
not sleep it just got up alright don't
kill me bro just let me get through here
I won't bother you just need to get my
hands on another little wooden doll and
Deuce hi hey come here you're gonna
follow me you're gonna follow me you
need to follow me little guy hey dick
whatever whatever that seems to be the
last one he's not following me now what
uh okay you're following me all right
fantastic yeah okay he's scampering
behind me like a little prick I'm gonna
show him a thing or two come on little
little Jimmy
let's just get this over with so I can
go forward through the door cuz
apparently hanging you will unlock the
door all I care about
come here come here don't done done okay
fires online feels like I've lost
something what about my soul you mean oh
god damn it feel like I've lost some
part
oh no haze post well I don't
oh there's blood here now well follow
the trail of blood oh well there's a
point of all of this hose the point
pause the point what's the point
I don't know I don't know maybe those
were little baby cages and I'm a
murdering psychopathic bastard I got to
get around this guy before I go to slip
again gotta get through the grave follow
the trail of blood do not kill me I'm
not in the mood to mess with you
following the blood just follow it
follow the giant trail of blood what was
that that a heart what do I have a heart
do I have to burn the heart I got to
burn the heart on the altar done well
this is normal if there's one thing I
can tell about this guy is that he is an
upstanding citizen respected in his
community like Oh boss man I'll tell you
I don't know where these games it I've
been fighting you've come in coming from
but okay okay
like this I don't like this I haven't
liked any of this but I don't like this
gosh damn it another one of these we got
to choose I choose this one
I'm just in a constant state of what the
hell is gonna happen next because you
know I thought things were getting stale
because they were doing the same jump
scares over and over again then they
threw the mannequins at me then things
just got a little weird
I had to murder the mannequins which I
think symbolizes me killing kids and
those that's what those cages were you
don't mess with me bro I don't even want
to be messed with
uh-uh even don't mess with me is this a
go to sleep one it's not time yet okay
okay stop it
self-five Gus slit I'm not going to slip
go to sleep go to look do it up
do not tell anything the name Sam what
does that even mean
I do not know stay away from what holds
you back
okay like what my heart which is now
beating and gonna stop follow the
darkness I don't want to follow the
freaking darkness day seven self-five my
potted plants are now thoroughly dead
follow the darkness follow the darkness
I'm quick I'm quick like bunny now
apparently oh good I'm outside what what
else what could you possibly do to me
run from that you're not to that run run
run run run run run run run go to sleep
go too late I'm not sleepy
he's gonna get me he's gonna get me
where am i running can I go pass him now
okay I can thoroughly go past him right
correct
okay rhyming past well that was some
what's in here
what why why don't make noises and don't
do anything
give me paranoid no um no thank you no
thank you no thank you
nothing here no they're on their way
Monson air are you out there lay Monson
air air alright I gotta find like a
sweatshirt
some there's a shovel in there that I
need to dig me up some graves which is
perfectly normal behavior I'm just
waiting for something to happen but
nothing's happening
that's pretty much the story of this
whole game I'm waiting for something to
happen enough
okay I'm locked in here now the mine
covers the truth as the light covers the
shadows okay well I can't move what's
going on let's go
hi no no
yes okay just just not okay get the
shovel dig us up some graves hey the
only logical thing to do now that's my
logic let's dig up them graves yeah yeah
boy yeah all right going grave robbing
yeah a black do this do this oh oh I got
to dig it all the way out empty it seems
that there's nothing it seems that there
is nothing empty then I'm pretty sure
because my vision went red around this
one no okay never mind all right then
whatever not like I needed those anyway
we're there any graves over here yeah
there were nope no empty I'll stop
asking why a long time ago so I'm just
gonna do it and be happy about it cuz
you can't enjoy the work you do there's
no point doing it you know you take
pride in what you do got take pride no
graves over here right okay let's go to
file some more sex a sanctified ground
sanctum
oh no the word I going in there no nope
lots of graves to dig okay yeah okay
yeah okay yeah okay yeah
nothing nothing nothing a whole lot of
nothing whole lotta nothing at least are
givin me a break from the constant
barrage of stuff
I spoke too soon didn't I
I spoke way too soon at least I'm
getting a break Burnham dramatic music
alright I love my job as a gravedigger
it seems that there is nothing is there
anything in here oh what a strange coin
I'm gonna throw it in the well for a
wish to get the hell out of here alright
I found it I might assume that there's
nothing else that I need but just double
checking to be sure I found a key let's
chug it in the wealth of good luck the
blood-soaked well alright oh man
alrighty what it's the only logical
thing to do it seems it whoa did these
gates open over here yes they dead all
right there we go we're a winner what
what what why I'm in space now or
something do I got to prepare the double
finger defense oh no I'm moving okay
alright let's just hop I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know what was going
on I didn't know so don't blame me I did
not know hello there's some behind me in
there
okay confused
yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep that was
expected that was expected where am i
now floating through space well my baby
cage what the hell wha what the hell is
going on
hahaha
what more can you do what more can you
do to me
I got land on a bed or something yeah I
landed on a bed I think
hey day eight is the nightmare over the
nightmare never over oh look what the
white key I am back what's a key they
get you into heaven or something it's a
lie right it's a lie it was a lie
bring it on [ __ ] I'm gonna lay the
smack down so hard you don't even know
hey Sam hi what's up hey been some
victims of severe trauma would retreat
into a fantasy world from which they
could not wake up in this catatonic
state the mind of the victim would often
try to wake them up with small details
as strange situations words noises or
even a video game to help them realize
they were asleep even then it would
often take days and tile they were ready
to please wake up
God owes incredible haha
how is some different guys I mean that
was a whole different experience just
the whole thing was just completely out
of my nightmare I mean it got it got
less scary after the mannequin part and
it kind of died down a bit which was
okay with me perfectly fine with me but
man that was good
that was really good that was really
good you guys got to play that for
yourselves or not if you don't want
nightmares cuz man oh man that was bad
whoo
I was fun good job to the developers of
that game you couldn't have been more
perfect on some of those scares so man
oh man I know this was a long one but it
was worth it alright so that's it let me
check out the extras to see if there's
something there oh just the credit okay
there's nothing there okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
Oh
but